where does river water go when it enters
the ocean does it spread out everywhere
does it do a loop-de-loop does it flow
along the coast it sounds like it should
be easy but it's anything but it's a
research problem I did it from my PhD
River water flowing down a river hits
the mouth and it enters the ocean but
where does it actually go we don't
really know I thought I always thought
just what would blast out to sea like in
a slowing plume the Coriolis force is
zero on the equator so the river Amazon
does just blast out in a plume like you
described but then when we move into the
northern hemisphere and the southern
hemisphere the Earth's rotation creates
this Coriolis force which is super super
important so that is going to cause your
River in the northern hemisphere to turn
to the right and you have to imagine it
when I say right you have to imagine
traveling down the river and as you
reach the coast turn right so that could
be east or west of heading on where your
rivers flow and then the southern
hemisphere same thing but you're gonna
turn to the left and we can see this the
satellite images you get this by doing
experiments that's what I did do some
experiments in the lab you know when
clockwise anti-clockwise you see right
and left did it without rotation and it
looks like the Amazon in that big blue
ultimately the Earth's rotation is the
most important factor in determining
where this river water goes because the
effect of the Coriolis force it actually
scales exactly as sine of latitude as in
the sine function so as you move further
away it gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and as you move further south it
gets more and more negative we want to
model a river entering the ocean so
here's our river this is our coast we're
gonna be in the northern hemisphere it's
being currently in the UK River water
comes in and then it's going to turn to
the right this is what the Coriolis
force does so the water's coming in it's
turning to the side and it's flowing
along the coast so what you actually get
are two very different features you see
these on satellite images or you can do
experiments you can actually see these
two things for me so there's this sort
of large whirlpool that forms near the
river mouth but there's this particular
point here where it divides so you're a
particle coming in you can either go
like this for a while or sort of stay
there or if you're near enough the edge
you sort of go around
you enter this current now the bit near
the source it's interesting from a mass
viewpoint but it's not super big in
terms of trying to understand this
problem you just have a big clump of
river water near your river mouth we
would expect that perhaps but then going
along the coast what we want to know is
well how far along the coast does this
river water go how deep is this river
water and maybe how far away from the
coast is it most of the pollution in our
oceans comes from rivers so if we're
going to start cleaning up our oceans
the sensible thing is to start where
there is the most pollution and this
could of course you know be either tiny
plastic beads or chemical pollution that
you can't see so it's not a case of
there's a giant blob of garbage let's
clean it up you need to think about you
to model this you need to think about
the physics the mass of it and you need
to be clever so what we want to know is
we want to know its width so I'm going
to call W naught we want to know how
fast it's going velocity U naught and we
want to know how deep it is and I'm
gonna call that H naught so if we're
looking at it from the side on you've
got your river surface with the waves
and you've got your sort of current here
which is going to be your fresh water
your river and then below it here you've
got your C your saltwater so this is the
view from above we want to know the
width of it how far off the coast wanna
know how fast it's moving and then if we
sort of flip it on its side we want to
know how far down in the ocean does that
current go because if we know these
things you know we clean up that amount
of distance from the coast we we clean
up the top layer of the ocean it's
incredibly important information we're
actually gonna clean up our oceans
fixing pollution and the max is also
awesome we're doing fluid mechanics
so the key thing really is to think
about what are the variables what are
the parameters they're actually going to
affect this particular situation so
first of all I've hopefully convinced
you that the Earth's rotation is
incredibly important if we're on the
equator with the Amazon it behaves very
differently in the northern hemisphere
the southern hemisphere so we're going
to have our Coriolis parameter our
rotation rate is going to be F it's
going to play such a major role that
we're also
to assume that this guy the rotation
dominates what else might affect the
movement of this water perhaps how much
water is leaving the river so what is
the the volume flux or the outflow rate
from our River so I'm going to call that
one Q Q is our volume flux so I've got a
giant river like the Amazon fed to a
tiny little stream different things will
happen and then it turns out the third
and final thing that we're going to need
is going to be the density difference
river water is going to float on top of
the salt water that's why we want to
know the depth of that top layer so
we're going to model that with what we
call the reduced gravity G Prime but for
our purposes that's just the density
difference it's just a formula which
involves the density of the river water
the density of the salt water the ocean
and gravity so these are our three key
parameters and importantly we've said
rotation dominates were then going to
have to make some more assumptions so
fluid mechanics means navier-stokes
equations I've talked a lot about
navier-stokes equations in the past so
I'm not going to do all of that again
but in short set of equations that model
the flow of every fluid they are super
difficult super tricky we don't really
understand them we can't really solve
them so we're going to make loads of
loads of assumptions so as I said first
assumption is rotation dominates we then
also assume that in our particular setup
the key velocity of our river current is
going to be in the direction along the
coast there will be some velocity in
this boundary current in this current
where you know it might move a little
bit this way and it might move a little
bit down or up but generally it's going
along the coast like the rotation is
pushing it in that direction so what
you're doing by by assuming that that
velocity is dominant you're reducing the
dimensions of the navier-stokes because
as we know we don't know if solutions
exist in 3d so let's not think about 3d
let's just consider 1d let's make it
easy for ourselves this is how we get
around the difficulty of the
navier-stokes in practice so we assume
we have this dominant velocity along the
coast and again we can look at satellite
data we can look at experiments and this
is true
it's gonna be our second assumption we
then assume something called a
hydrostatic pressure which basically
just say is that your pressure only
matters in the depth of the water we
don't need to worry too much about what
that means but it helps us a lot so we
have that and then we're gonna have two
final things the next one is going to be
that our ocean is infinitely deep
ridiculous
I don't know but bear with me because
the idea here is as we will see with
with our eventual answers the river
current that bit of fresh water on top
of the ocean it's pretty shallow right
so we're talking 10 to 20 meters
compared to an ocean that's hundreds of
meters deep so it seems at least to me
hopefully to everybody else that the the
fact that your ocean is so much deeper
than that top 10 meters it's hundreds of
meters down you don't expect the bottom
of the ocean to interfere with the top
layer of your river water so it may as
well be infinitely deep and by doing
that it makes the maths a lot easier
which is always nice and then our very
final thing which is sort of the key to
the whole model is that the potential
vorticity is conserved so in short it
says that your vorticity is sort of how
swirly you're it's like the the
whirlpool enos swirl enos of your water
it just says that if that's at a
particular value it will stay at that
value it's something we do all the time
in fluid mechanics so we assume that the
PV potential vorticity is conserved we
have these three important parameters
rotation rate volume flux the amount of
water coming in and the density
difference we make these five
assumptions and as if by magic we get
these incredibly nice formulae for the
three things were interested in ever
nervious stokes equations we'll give
them to yes so it starts in a via Stokes
but we're using the the classic applied
mathematician trick of let's just make
all of these assumptions and worry about
whether they were good or bad at the end
when we get our result and what we find
we get this really neat formula to say
that the maximum depth H naught is equal
to two times the rotation rate times the
volume flux
divided by
density difference or to the half even
though we started with the navier-stokes
equations these incredibly complicated
mathematical things we don't understand
it's amazingly genuinely is amazing that
this pops out from from such a
complicated set of equations and and you
can think a little bit about whether
this makes sense this is saying that the
river current gets deeper when your
rotation rate is larger says the river
current gets deeper when your volume
flux is larger you have more water
leaving your river you expect that the
resulting current to be deeper and then
finally it says that it's deeper when
your density difference is smaller so
the density of the two waters are really
close together they mix together really
well
whereas when they're really far apart
you've got super salty ocean water
really fresh river water they don't mix
you know it's like mixing water and oil
versus mixing salt water fresh water you
get that difference so it all makes
perfect sense and it came out of the
equation and it involves the three
things we thought were important Tom not
being very familiar with these actual
parameters like what a flux density is
and that sort of stuff
what type of numbers do you normally get
from typical yeah earth sized rivers so
so F is really small F is one rotation
of the earth in 24 hours so F is tiny
right because the Earth's huge so it
moves very very slow Q the volume flux
so the river rhine is the the biggest
river in the North Sea one of the ones I
studied with this work and that we
compared and got similar results
satellite data you're looking at like
2,000 meters Q per second for the
density difference if your fresh water
is is a thousand then your ocean waters
a thousand and twenty five sort of is
one way of measuring it so it's slightly
slightly more dense so to the G prime
value is Jones to be quite small so F is
quite small G prime is quite small but Q
can be quite big so how deep does that
give us what kind of dips sorry so for
the River Rhine this guy comes out at
about 10 to 20 meters because of course
it will vary depending on the the season
so in the summer there's a smaller
volume flux you know the densities might
be more similar whereas in the winter
really large volume flux everything's
gonna happen in different seasons but
you get a volume between 10 20 me
you measure it with a hip and you
measure on the satellite it's about 10
meters deep so it's sort of it's giving
us the right kind of values so we're
going to clean up the North Sea along
the coast of the Netherlands France and
Germany we only need to clean the top 10
meters that's the kind of knowledge you
can get from from these models then we
also get the the width so the width is
important because we want to know how
far offshore to clean up thinking
practically we want to know do we clean
up 10 20 kilometers out to sea or do we
have to go all the way out 100
kilometers and we get a really neat
formula for the width W naught we've got
an 8 this time G prime Q divided by F
cubed or to the 1/4 like before let's
think a little bit does this make sense
if we have a larger volume flux we
expect it to be deeper and we expect it
to be wider there's more water if we
have a larger density difference this is
telling us that it's going to be wider
so we saw that it was shallower and here
this is telling us it will be wider
again if you've got the same amount of
water but you change the density
difference if this is shallower it's got
it's got to go somewhere so it sort of
goes wider becomes further away and then
with the rotation if the rotation is
larger think about that while those
fairground rides where you're in that
sort of circular thing and it spins
really fast and you'll push back against
the wall so the faster it goes the more
you're forced outwards so you get expect
it to be less wide because you're forced
more towards the coast the faster it's
moving and this guy is gonna spit out
it's around 10 to 20 kilometers so it's
much bigger than the top one because F
is so small because F is tiny we've got
it cubed on the bottom to get a much
bigger number so this is now kilometres
10 to 20 kilometers for the river rhine
again it's around 20 kilometers on the
satellites so so we know just clean up
top 10 meters 20 kilometers out to sea
and then our final result we can get the
velocity so the velocity is going to
follow a similar pattern except the
numbers this time are ridiculous so we
have three over two to the nine quarters
maybe my favorite number F G prime Q to
the 1/4 again let's just think about
does this make sense we go faster if the
rotates faster at our experiment rotates
faster okay you know that seems sensible
if there's a large a density difference
they're not going to mix as much so if
they're not using their energy to mix
they're probably going to use that
energy to go faster and then again if
there's more water it's going to be
pushed through faster so they all make
complete physical sense this gives us a
value of around one meter per second so
not super fast but again the River Rhine
it's around not 0.5 to 1 meters per
second as well so all of them are within
the ballpark and this kind of knowledge
actually then you know we can use this
we can go out to the River Rhine go out
to the the Dutch coast and start using
this putting this to practice and
cleaning up our oceans by just doing
some maths some navier-stokes some
assumptions and sort of getting these
really neat for me they're explaining
what's happening it's plume or this
current that goes along the coast
obviously it's constantly being fed by
more and more water as the river just
keeps flowing and flowing and flowing
how long is this plume how does it end
does the pollutants follow the whole
coast of Europe everyone yeah great
question say the the River Rhine plume
flows along the Dutch coast and there
long Germany and then it hits the sort
of the corner bit where Denmark then
pops up and in that corner is the river
Elbe which is the second largest river
in the Nazi so it kind of merges into
the outflow from the river Elbe and then
the river Elbe flows up along the coast
of Denmark and then goes into the Baltic
Sea and then sort of all gets trapped in
the Baltic Sea and then you've got all
kinds of different things happening in
there because it's quite a stagnant
ocean and it only has one Inlet in and
out and it's quite large so you get
weird things going on in the Baltic Sea
and entering a different sort of
modeling regime different physics
happening there
this video was the third in a kind of
trilogy about navier-stokes equations to
see the other two there are links on the
screen and in the video description the
full navier-stokes equations as written
down in our piece of paper
hang on which way around are we if we're
talking this if yeah